- You try to be a good employee.
You show up, you
sit at your desk,
you move things around on it,
you update your screensaver,
you finally find
the nearest printer.
But sometimes it's
still all just too much.
So here's a tip, leave early.
Leaving early, while
it sounds challenging,
is actually really easy and
great for your mental health.
Here's the first thing you do.
Create an event in your
calendar for the last half hour
of the day that you're
supposed to be there.
Now I have to
invite some people.
I'm gonna go with
this list of interns
who don't work here anymore.
I'm also gonna invite
an actual employee,
Peter Vietz, who will
get an email about it
and then email me saying he
didn't know there was a meeting
and I'll say, "Sorry, I
looped you in accidentally."
Now, at the same
time I'm gonna book
a conference room on
the seventh floor.
There are never any
conference rooms
on the seventh floor available.
So that means Dan M, who works
in conference room booking,
is gonna email me saying that,
and I'm gonna say, "Oh
no problem, I'm gonna
"move my meeting
back to my office."
Now I'm professional
and considerate.
Ta da, and now I
have two alibis.
So now, when I hang this sign
on my office at
the end of the day,
no one can say I
wasn't in a meeting.
And that, ladies and
gentlemen, is how
you have a healthy
work life balance.
Now, if you'll excuse me, I
have a gym membership to cancel.